it's time to babble the [ __ ] on
[Music]
it's hollywood babylon
with your hosts kevin smith and ralph
garvin
[Music]
oh my god uh
well first listen it's [ __ ] saturday
night in burbank so let's battle the
[ __ ] out
i'm your host kevin smith and i'm your
other host ralph garner
how many takes we're gonna do tonight
they uh for those listening at home and
and boring in the room they
started the show while me and ralph were
taking a leak together yes
we were crossing the streams we
literally were and all of a sudden we
heard the music that sounds familiar
yeah it's a good thing the music
happened because both of us dick out
magic could have happened as well
and then we're like oh we can't [ __ ]
think about that now we got a show to do
that's right
welcome everybody this is the four year
anniversary of the day i almost [ __ ]
died
but it's important to add he didn't
for anyone who might be confused
that was the marketing hook for the show
tonight
he's alive
um the uh do we have a clip of the this
is what i was doing four years ago uh
technically
let me see it happened on the tonight of
the 25th at like nine o'clock at night
so by the time i
tweeted and instagrammed about it it was
the next day yeah
most people in my life were like
i was i [ __ ] read something online
and then i was gonna call you
but then i thought i'd check instagram
first sure
and you already posted yeah i knew [ __ ]
was okay
so um before i uh went to the hospital
we had shot of uh two specials well one
special
one of two we were going to shoot that
night for a showtime special by comedy
dynamics and so
as the show was ending
i did not feel
bad or unwell or feel like oh my god
[ __ ] i'm getting sick
um i wouldn't know for for another 20
minutes
until i hit the dressing room that i was
like something [ __ ] feels wrong and
[ __ ] like that so
i asked ralph to pull a clip
from the end of the show this is one of
the last things
i ever would have said like publicly
yeah if i had
dropped dead which probably
might have been better than me saying
i don't know maybe spider-man could have
been one of the 10 films nominated for
best picture
if i died that night ralph i would not
have [ __ ] lived through the hell that
i received for saying that non-fucking
heated statement yes
but think of all the hummus recipes we
would have missed out on oh
[ __ ] christ
again with the hummus i made you some
[ __ ] hummus man
look at that [ __ ] and i i topped it but
it's smooshed around the corner very
pretty well no [ __ ] pretty you're
going to try it [ __ ]
thank you uh look i brought it here i
don't want to touch your [ __ ] chip
take the spoon all right
try this it's a magic trick yes
the magic is you're going to be alone
any spoon how did i ever [ __ ] live
without this do you eat hummus i do i
enjoy hummus grapes oh then [ __ ] dig
in watch us watch this all right
you better [ __ ] like it
i'm painting it's delicious it's legit
[ __ ] good right legit good i'm not
trying to sell it or anything like that
but i just why not
because you want honestly you want to
know why miss thomas can i tell you a
quick story about one i'm supposed to be
hummus here today or something you can
figure something no dude the [ __ ]
easy name is kevin smith's homosexual
[Music]
um i've given it some thought but uh
we're doing another movies pop-up uh in
los angeles coming very soon uh yeah so
i won't be able to
go to hollywood for that i know a lot of
people in burbank are like hollywood
[ __ ] that um it's only 20 minutes away
[ __ ] uh so
yes we'll be doing another uh movies
pop-up and um [ __ ] why was i telling
that story about selling hummus oh so
thank you
so they were like hey man we should just
[ __ ] you keep you know instagramming and
tweeting about hummus we should sell
kev's special hummus and use your recipe
and i was like i don't want to do that
and they're like yeah right and i was
like no seriously and they're like why
jordan was like why and i was like look
literally everything i do
in life yeah gets judged
by [ __ ] i've never met this is true
and some [ __ ] you have met yeah
um
but
this like
i don't wanna i don't i don't wanna put
that in the world so somebody could
tweet
[ __ ] sucks you know [ __ ] like that i
get a lot of joy out of making that
hummus so i was
this is for me leave this for me and she
said tweeted me a broken uh text me a
broken heart emoji
and was like fine keep your [ __ ]
hummus so this is only for like friends
and family i know it's rude not to bring
for everybody but
yeah yeah
i would take a lot of tahini to feed
this room you would
um good right very good i can't believe
you only did one spoonful i did two i
did another one while you were talking
did you just all right well feel free
i'm gonna leave it open please do it
like grace girls knock along
um anyway
you got garlic in there i i topped it
with little uh tahin and uh uh a
baked falafel and uh everything
like uh everything not everything i hope
yes i was like
he'll love this
um everything but the bagel oh yeah yeah
yeah right trader joe's so good and a
little olive oil and [ __ ] lovely thanks
for you thank you i was thinking of you
tonight when i was making it i was like
oh i'm making something for my special
guy
you're so old-fashioned
and everything wow if i hear your yard
on date four year anniversary that's
right um you weren't there that night
but that's not your [ __ ] i wasn't no
no no no no when did you find out
um
i found out
forget who it was someone messaged me
and said i was going to see kevin
tonight but they said he left the
theater early he was sick
so then i reached out to jen your lovely
wife and i said is everything okay and
she said no it's not okay i'm on the way
to the hospital so that's how i found it
jesus
you know i find out yeah i do
yeah probably when they were strapping
you on a journey i would assume
so in any event at the end of the show
right before like i got off the stage i
was like something right and within an
hour they were [ __ ] rushing me to the
hospital in an ambulance this is what i
said well can we roll that clip
over the course of your life you've
listened to people talk on the radio or
seen people talk on tv and you've said
to yourself or thought to yourself i'm
smarter than these people
i'm funnier than this person you're
probably thinking that [ __ ] right now
and you're probably right man but
nobody's gonna know unless you kind of
go out there and express yourself in
some way shape or form share of yourself
now some people don't want to because
they're afraid that it might not work
and [ __ ] like that like oh what if i
fail but there is no such thing as
[ __ ] failure failure is just success
training i know that sounds like a cat
poster but it's [ __ ] true like nobody
ever [ __ ] gets something right on the
first try and [ __ ] don't be afraid of
failure don't let that keep you from
trying something that you might want to
try and stuff like that rather fail
spectacular then live your life
wondering like i wonder if that [ __ ]
would have worked out that's how i've
just kind of conducted myself for the
last like 20 25 years and it's led on
this weird [ __ ] journey so uh the
cats who come out and support me and see
the shows and stuff i always want to try
to give something back at the end of the
day like you've given me so much you've
given me a way to not have to [ __ ]
work for a living so like you know i
always want to try to give back i could
give the money back but [ __ ] that so
like
the least i could give back is i know
there are people in the audience that
are like i kind of want to do what you
do and you absolutely [ __ ] can you
know i'm i'm going to tell you something
that maybe like you don't hear that much
anymore because you're adults and [ __ ]
and it's our job to say this to younger
people and [ __ ] but this is the true
sentiment a stranger is going to [ __ ]
tell you this week so [ __ ] get ready
you are smart and good you're all
[ __ ] talented you all have something
amazing to [ __ ] say
so
find a way
find a way to [ __ ] share that i i've
like i'm 47 years old and i'm still
trying to figure out who the [ __ ] i am
so before you leave this world figure
out who you are at your core man
wouldn't
before you leave this world
how amazing would it have been if those
were my last [ __ ] words man
like he was talking about before he
lived this world and he [ __ ] left
this world
and he also said he hadn't figured
himself out yet before he left the world
how sad is that so weird man but the
[ __ ] doctor mark ladenheim saved my
life and now you got to figure out who
you are now i got to think of other cool
[ __ ] to say
you know it's just like [ __ ] ending
on a perfect note and you're like all
right [ __ ] take me jesus but jesus
did not take me and [ __ ]
he saw dogma
[Laughter]
he doesn't want your ass it's like why'd
you have to make fun of my dad
um anyway that was four years ago but
today uh here we are the only reason i
wanted to show that clip is because i
look so much better than i did in that
clip it's crazy i noticed when i was
looking at that it's uh you've lost a
person it's great um this recently i
i've lost a little more i've been hiking
running today was day 47 of my hooks up
running and [ __ ] my goal
for this show is to be able to put on a
blazer i've worn a blazer on stage in
quite some time so this is a big night
for me probably a little early for it
because i'm really like sucking it in if
you see me turn blue it's because i'm
like but you know you [ __ ] you gotta
you gotta make you know work up to it
right i don't really suck yourself into
it i've been wearing too loose clothing
again and that just leads to
no [ __ ] good too much hummus and [ __ ]
like
so yeah it's nice to be here and nice to
be here amongst you all well thank you
for selling us out tonight kevin coming
out we appreciate that thank you
to celebrate him staying alive
the show would be a lot harder if you
weren't alive
you honestly we've done so many shows
that you could like use one of those
programs or you put all of babylon
into a computer and then it sorts out my
language yeah so you say [ __ ] and then
you just press a button just type in
yourself and i say the same standard
[ __ ] anyway so
it just [ __ ] comes up i just hit
elvis and it goes on for about 20
minutes
you're right it would be pretty easy you
just need a hologram
can't wait till you love anything
i love you
all right
can't make fun of that no you can't
hey stop it yeah [ __ ] you josh you play
the intro again josh
[Laughter]
oh
you gotta be careful man that will
literally hurt josh's feelings right
after the show he's gonna [ __ ] mean
muggy so hard
it's time to yeah exactly
why not
[Applause]
let's hear it for dr josh rouse by the
way who dug our sights and sounds every
episode
couldn't do it without him
can i show you something i just got
given outside before the show began sure
people are [ __ ] crazy talented man
uh this is by shannon who on instagram
goes by she put her name in the shoe she
told me she goes by one crafty punk the
number one crafty punk please [ __ ]
wow she made
super cool and then on the back look at
this [ __ ] bonus quick stop on the back
stuff i [ __ ] out like i just come to do
a show and [ __ ] and [ __ ] somebody's
like here's new footwear
and i will legit [ __ ] wear this of
course you will pretty sweet skips man
sometimes it's nice to be like
quasi-famous and [ __ ] people just give
you things yeah same way i gave you
hummus yeah same thing
because you're famous thanks
speaking of famous how goes the ralph
report it goes well thank you so much i
think we got a lot of garmin members
here tonight thank you guys hanging in
there a lot of garmi folks here man yeah
sold us out
um this is probably not going to matter
by the time people hear it but uh um
emergency situation nothing bad came up
but eddie pence usually does the show
with me he's not available to do the
show on monday so sitting in will be
kevin smith on the ralph report on
monday
a little bonus me and [ __ ] ralph all
weekend long yeah
using our mouths
weekend at ralphies
which one of us rhymes up the dead
puppet
well you almost died i'll go this time
[Laughter]
oh that would suck man because then like
sooner or later somebody you know i in
that movie they never got in trouble for
hanging out with the dead guy no charges
were pressed
but like by the time we do our first
when's our next babylon show uh next
month march 16th i think march 16th if
you died and i weekend that [ __ ]
burnied you and [ __ ] all the way to the
show
and that's when you like fell apart like
you decayed and your head fell off put
me in the freezer i don't know come on
that's too much work you're too heavy
so by the time all that [ __ ] happened i
wanted you know i'd be getting arrested
like andrew mccarthy didn't get arrested
but they'd be like what did you do to
your friend and i'm like i didn't he
just [ __ ] died and i was trying to
keep the act going i mean
i don't know it's a little shady but
it's not legal is it they're like [ __ ]
yes it's illegal turns out it is
well what do you say we talked to some
folks here who came from particularly
long distances or celebrating special
occasions with us tonight it's our
segment we call the shout outs
it's a shout out
kevin
still got it
that [ __ ] is brave in the age of covert
i'll tell you that right now
holy [ __ ] i smeared some hummus on time
i moved on and i never wouldn't let it
go
uh speaking of brave is such a weird
pivot uh but like
[ __ ] i know we're here to have a good
time and [ __ ] but obviously there's a
war happening elsewhere yes
the president of ukraine
president zielinski oh my god dude what
a rock star if somebody was like
we got a plane for you because you're
number one on a kill list
i feel like they wouldn't finish the
sentence i'd be on the plane be like
let's go let's go
and even if like let's say [ __ ] like
you know they didn't offer me a [ __ ]
flight out and [ __ ] as soon as [ __ ]
uncle red the ruski's rolled up i'd be
like who's dick do i gotta suck
to stay alive you know not even to save
the country just to save my [ __ ] ass
i'm a coward at heart i know it
this [ __ ] guy is literally just
batman he's just like i'm not going
anywhere i'm staying on the [ __ ]
ground i said i don't need a ride i need
ammunition oh my god like could you ima
i'll never be
a quarter
of the man and he started in a similar
field he was a [ __ ] tv comedian yeah
we're not we're podcast comedians we're
not even that [ __ ] good and [ __ ]
but could you imagine like dude is there
anything in this world that you would be
that brave about like if somebody was
like [ __ ] it's it's it's red dawn and
the [ __ ] tanks are rolling down
[ __ ]
yeah
would you fight for hollywood and [ __ ]
you knew that was silly the minute it
left your mouth didn't you
it's your fight for hollywood
that battle's already been lost
wait where do you live in the valley
would you fight for the valley
no
[ __ ] we're in the valley oh that's true
uh really you wouldn't fight for
anything uh what if they want all right
[ __ ] you what if they were like what if
the ruskies were like oh [ __ ] man philly
that's what we want
sign me up where's my gun man would you
really go back [ __ ] yeah
no
yeah
oh my god for a second i was doubting
myself going like what's wrong with me i
figured at some point i had to try to
act brave
you're a [ __ ] good actor thank well
it's doing something
but
let's uh let's
a ninja let's
let's give it up man for president
zielinski jesus yes absolutely a [ __ ]
hero
[Applause]
crazy
anyway here we go all right
uh i don't think anyone here is from the
ukraine but probably people came from
long distances to celebrate with us
tonight like caitlyn and samson
that's how it's done katelyn at
caitlin and sampson
[Laughter]
stand up sampson
just give me one of these like what's up
what's up i was expecting [ __ ] a long
mane and [ __ ] but
this is one thing animals telling that
well this is when they've cut his hair
and he's all weak and can't bring the
temple down and [ __ ]
you just told everyone you're a coward i
don't know if they'd be picking fights
with people
it's you and me samson holy [ __ ] when
the reds come rolling up let's start
sucking you know what i'm
saying better
red in the mouth than dead whatever they
used to say
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyway what's up with these cats caitlyn
says my husband is a huge fan not
anymore not after
that no i got [ __ ] clothes with you
and me
okay we're buddies we've been listening
to you both for years this is our first
live show well thanks for coming
welcome you should have led with that
i'm sorry
look at that they got some [ __ ]
applause man right
samson's a patron of the ralph report
never misses an episode thank you so
much sir we drove up from laguna beach
to celebrate our 10-year wedding
anniversary oh my god wow well laguna
beach
and wow 10 years
you got about five more till the wheels
fall off
at least that's what i found personally
i don't
i don't know if that's the same with
everybody but
i no no it's no no it's not but you know
i'm definitely giving you your [ __ ]
divorce study space
to actually press your
truth yes samson's a big original batman
fans i was wondering if adam west could
wish us a happy anniversary caitlyn and
samson
why of course i'll jump
hold on hold on man who are you josh
roush i didn't have my camera
you know we filmed the show i know but
but you know dr josh roush loves it when
i give him [ __ ] video that it can pop
in and [ __ ]
so don't look at see the hummus i mean
yeah the hummus more hummus
[Laughter]
you have an eta on the uh the camera
we're getting there
show's only 90 minutes hold on here we
go and
you're going over to samson all right
widescreen you want is that josh
[Laughter]
he loves what you do except everything
you've done up to this point
just saying man [ __ ] i'm a director i
know what i'm doing
but he's right it should be what okay
here we go
and action
samson
old chum
happy 10th anniversary
i'm glad you married caitlyn instead of
that evil vixen delilah
[Laughter]
that's a thinker
happy anniversary you two
leave here peacefully go home and make
sweet sweet love
for about another five years
there you go happy anniversary kiss
maria crystal and adriana
hello right up front oh it was so
tremendous
i thought sookie was in that potties
yeah
uh they drove all the way from fresno
snooki why did i say suki i don't know
oh you guys came from fresno
that's in california
barely
yeah is it past sacramento which one's
maria which one is brian
[Laughter]
this was a last-minute girls trip but i
heard there'd be a show the same time we
were in l.a i begged my husband alex to
let me buy tickets he put me onto your
podcast a few years back we've always
wanted to come see a show but three kids
later and life happened and we just
never got the chance he agreed to stay
home with the kids this weekend so i
could take this trip
i feel terrible because i know how much
he would love to be here you don't feel
that terrible though do you really
could sexy kev tell him how sorry and
grateful i am in return when i get home
i'll finally let him slip through the
back door
alex also sent an email but he refused
to let me read it so could you find it
let me know what he said i happen to
have it here
[Applause]
alex writes ralph do me a favor and give
give her some [ __ ] as sylvester stallone
for leave me alone with the kids
and have sexy kevin tell me what she's
going to do to make it up to me when she
gets home so oh my god
that's yeah that's like the newlywed
game when you both have the same answer
that's right your guys are meant to be
shouldn't have left them over the kids
you know it's like he's like working
hard you know like me living for you and
then you're like well leave with your
girls go to the dances like what did i
drink and watch clowns
and now sexy kevin
[Music]
alex
you're being sexy talked to by a man
doesn't that make you [ __ ] hard
your wife wants me to cuck it out
[ __ ] say dirty [ __ ] to you
i gotta say anything dirtier than this
three kids what are you in your [ __ ]
mind
[Laughter]
wrap that rascal you [ __ ]
once she gets home man [ __ ] maria
maria right
yeah maria
you know what i'm talking about
maria's gonna let you into the back man
she's gonna show you just paradise my
friend she's gonna show you that
sometimes
flowers don't smell that great but
they're still beautiful
[Music]
dropped out of character there a little
bit true yeah
uh my advice is be super gentle man lots
of [ __ ] lube and in fact
if you want to know how gentle you
should be let her [ __ ] you first up the
ass
[Music]
then you do what she did
good luck alex
three kids what uh what's the breakdown
of the kids gender
was a girl she's gonna be nine on
tomorrow on monday actually nine
tomorrow oh my god tell her happy
birthday
oh god delighted you are i will i will
tell a nine-year-old that
a strange 51 year old man
and his even older buddy
over there
sad shade
um but yes please do
do you not care for the middle one so
much i don't talk about that one
is that bruno we don't talk about bruno
what's the middle one
the middle one is five five five
um all right whose birthday is it
the oldest one what's her name what's
her name natalie natalie all right so
this goes up online so let's [ __ ]
sing to this kid they'll blow her
[ __ ] mind
it'll really [ __ ] give her an uh un
realistic idea of how life works
she'll have this i remember when [ __ ]
i was nine years old they got a new fire
truck in my town in highlands and they
had an event called the wet down when it
parked a [ __ ] truck in the middle of
bay ave shut all the streets put up the
[ __ ] cherry picker and then launch
the hose and let kids just dance and
water and they had rides and [ __ ] and i
was like it's gonna be like this every
year for the rest of my life and it
never happened again because they only
do that [ __ ] when they get a new fire
truck that's true and the next time they
get a new fire truck i was a grown-ass
man not there and then he would do a
[ __ ] wet down that being said if we
do this video for this nine-year-old
[ __ ] kid yeah
she'll think that every year of her life
strangers will sing a [ __ ] song to
her
so you're looking forward to setting her
up for a big letdown the teacher said
it's a [ __ ] reality here's your gift
it was only good that once man it
teaches you to reach for more and [ __ ] i
had to find something better than a wet
down and i did
that's not your last last wet down
you've ever had i bet
technically no no no
um what's the kid's name
natalie that [ __ ]
i'm a stoner [ __ ] i [ __ ]
said a lot of [ __ ] between then and now
the kid's name was hummus you'd remember
it don't [ __ ] yeah
i mean to be fair i think anyone would
remember that
that's a particular name oh that's
[ __ ] if i had another kid that's the
kid's name
thomas i made hummus literally um
all right natalie here we go man [ __ ]
everybody singing together you know what
i'm going to shoot this [ __ ] oh what
could go wrong
because josh will want me to shoot it
because then we could show everybody you
know singing otherwise just this they'll
have one angle of us and then one angle
of the crowd including her [ __ ] mom
so like when she's 30 she'll be able to
watch this and be like my [ __ ] mom
was out getting drunk without my dad
she left me it was great what the [ __ ]
was going on
this video haunts me
it's like a [ __ ] wet down
all right here we go
on the count of three i'm starting you
and i'm going to slowly troll the room
and probably do it twice because the
song's a little long oh [ __ ] unless she
wants to get [ __ ] super fast
twice
what could go right with this thing
you're about to start here
we'll do it regular time
captain
count three one two three happy
birthday hold on hold on hold on oh for
[ __ ] sake
i i i talk to you before i press the
button so i missed out every week i
write 90 minutes of material why do i do
that
how have i not learned by now
no you do over prepare i do
all right here we go hold on i'm
pressing record
now sit one two three happy birthday to
you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear natalie
[Music]
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday natalie
i stopped before that yeah i
didn't know you were gonna ad lib there
so you put the camera on me i'm a garner
you really are yeah um that'll be
[ __ ] sweet man
it's worth [ __ ] dropping a justin
bieber story for
although justin bieber recently saved
[ __ ] tim hortons did you see that i
saw the tim beep sold through
[ __ ] huge the guy who owned sim
horton was just like
i owe this [ __ ] kid everything so
he's he's he's gonna be here with us
forever
you're a downer
i feel bad for the five-year-old kid she
doesn't remember his name doesn't bring
him up
we should do a video for that kid that's
the kid who needs the video
your mom forgot you
all right
robert midlow
yep hi robert robert says my friend
jamie and i will be joining you on the
february 26 show we could not miss the
anniversary of kevin staying alive
because we were both in line four years
ago to see the second show
seriously
i'm trying to put on twice the show that
i would have done that night
uh my god man would you like some hummus
[Laughter]
i always felt bad for the people who
were in line for the second show when i
was
being loaded into the ambulance like you
know it was in one of those it's a chair
that becomes a
a stretcher it's like a transformer
when i was being loaded in there were
people lined up for the next show toward
the back of the gate
and so
i i guess they believe
i had no choice i was queen waving to
them and [ __ ] and i guess they had been
told
that i was sick that i had food
poisoning because there was a guy
outside the fence who was going like
this
and i was just like this [ __ ]
sees me getting loaded into an ambulance
still wants me to blow him and [ __ ] like
people are mean man
um but yeah i always felt bad for the
folks that didn't get a second show what
what did did you get anything or were
they like go home
yeah they seated everybody and then said
[ __ ] off robert's pissed he said we had
really good seats
did you really
oh my god you [ __ ] robert bev
what have you thought about you oh my
artery is completely closed oh
i'm dying what about other people kevin
[ __ ] things all i can think about is
like holding on to dear life i don't
think about robert at all exactly
god damn it that's why that's why i
almost died
and when i was on the [ __ ] table
[ __ ] i almost
like passed on but [ __ ] some spirit
i'm not gonna say it was god it was just
like you go back and be better to robert
that's right and that's why i've been
here and it's taken me four years to
reconnect and [ __ ] goddamn i'm gonna
be better to you that's right do you
like a pair of free sneakers
here's something we can do for robert oh
he said i was at a babylon show about
five or six years ago and i asked you to
video a message as the germans to my
friend ernie and his soon-to-be wife
congratulating them on their nuptials
i've attached that video can we take a
look a little bit of that video
ah hello
good times
they're taking a punch
yeah
that's actually cute
robert continues well that marriage
didn't work out
oh wait how long ago was that five or
six years ago oh wow ernie's had his
heart broken by his wife oh ernie it was
probably that video
his wife saw in that day she was like oh
no i gotta rethink this guy can you
record a new message as the germans on
how he doesn't need her and how single
life will be great and he's still a
winner
did they actually get married yeah yeah
and then it all went down then one day
she was just like i don't want to be
married anymore yeah you got your camera
on you in there robert come here or oh
yeah i guess that makes more sense
i was gonna shoot it and i thought josh
put in the video but he could have it in
his
sometimes i'm just dumb as [ __ ] i really
don't [ __ ]
think
pleasure man how are you everyone give
it up for robert
robert got [ __ ] four years ago but
tonight we're gonna make it up to him
yeah all right [ __ ] all right the
germans to ernie leave my gut out
hi ernie good to see you again my friend
yeah even though we can't see you yeah
yeah we're good to speak with you again
i guess that's probably more accurate
remember what we said all those years
ago about nathan yeah we have to plunge
into the dupont
forget all that she was a [ __ ]
we hate her
we don't know her oh we know her we know
her kind
she rips out your heart and then stomps
on it and says the marriage is over
oh we know we're going ernie
you have to understand one of us is
divorced
that's not why i'm saying that no
it's for ernie my heart bleeds for him
and you're still a winner ernie you're
still a vienna yeah you know what you
say to your pain
yeah yeah i feel it i feel the same 90
there you go give that to him
thank you robert
just waiting for the next email megan
and ernie got back together again and
i would be all right then if that was
the case i wouldn't record another video
for that
i imagine their three-part [ __ ]
series but
chronicling their
marriage the ups and downs of two
[ __ ] will never meet yes
back as an extra he won that contest
ernie was the dp
i know ernie
me and jay still talk about him
i swear to god man jay for whatever
reason is so [ __ ] up for whatever
reason
hold on no i'm good but whatever
for whatever reason jay they're gonna
cut to liam neeson's [ __ ] we're just
gonna go
is there anybody's got time is anybody
following us i don't know we're good
yeah um for for uh for whatever reason
he loves of everything we've done
jason muse loves the blunt cave stuff
like that he's like you need to do more
[ __ ] like that that was funny and i'm
like what about the rest of the [ __ ]
we've done since since then 20 years
later he's like is good but [ __ ]
remember when like pauldini was the
clapper
and he comes out and looks at us and he
goes you guys look pretty badass
throw away line nobody left jason muse
would be pissing his pants
even now watching it he's like that's so
[ __ ] up
he's not an actor like
it's crazy but in any event we always
talk about he's like who was the guy who
was the dp
and i was like it was ernie he won a
contest through wizard was it or through
wizard magazine that's so [ __ ] up
please tell them
we still talk about them
and not like poorly like [ __ ] that
ernie what a dick
like you know we [ __ ] talk about him
like [ __ ] wistfully like who was that
[ __ ] who came into our lives
touched us briefly and then disappeared
but here i gotta get to the [ __ ]
update last time we shot a video
did you tell me that i knew ernie i'm so
i'm having the same reaction that i had
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god that's even sweeter now
[Laughter]
i never knew there'd be a price to pay
for all that weed smoking really just
seems hard could ask me
well i look forward to remembering ernie
again sometime in the future
next crisis he goes through when we do a
video
we're all going to relive ernie
oh it makes me feel bad that [ __ ]
that guy's lady [ __ ] left him yeah
she didn't know what she had i mean i
only knew him for like 12 hours but
ernie was good [ __ ] people 21 years
ago
still is right so it was her fault she's
the bad one yeah we hate her yeah
team ernie man yeah forever ernie
forever [ __ ] what was her name
oh my god we're still here yeah
the shout outs yeah
i'm not surrendering i'm like ukraine
i'm just
i'm gonna keep fighting on
i'm fighting for something
here adrian where are you where the [ __ ]
are you adrian where are you adrian how
are you sir i give it up for adrian
adrian's here
four-star general in the garden god
bless you sir oh [ __ ] look at that four
star you must be rich
everyone jump adrian in the parking lot
he's [ __ ] rich
congratulations to kevin on surviving
and thriving from the widowmaker thank
you we haven't talked about the
widowmaker enough it sounds like such a
badass name doesn't it does yeah i
usually attend shows with my gorgeous
girlfriend but not tonight because she's
a front line worker and although we all
want this pandemic to be over the virus
is not done with us yet her hospital
workforce is currently short staffed and
stretched thin so she could not take the
night off to help celebrate mr smith
with me you know what like
more needed where she is absolutely
let's give it up for
the the actual what's her name
he's getting too yeah i'll get to it
now you know how i feel adrian
[Laughter]
it's also her birthday by the way oh
[ __ ] yes so she extends her greetings
and congratulations to kevin as well i'd
like to make a request on behalf of her
birthday to have david bowie sing happy
birthday to her
i ordinarily i would tell you her name
but apparently it's a slur now she never
even wants to speak to the manager she
doesn't throw public temper tantrums
yes
[Laughter]
ever since i no longer call her karen
i've heard her as k word
oh is that right do you have to call her
k word all the time could david bowie
please sing k word happy birthday well
yeah i think we could do that like a
little music there josh
[Music]
happy birthday to uk world
happy birthday to uk world we're sorry
you work on your birthday
and we all really really miss you
happy birthday to uk world
from us here on
happy birthday
happy birthday
karen let's just say it man [ __ ]
she's doing too much good to not use
your real name yeah
yeah you married karen you keep [ __ ]
caring man
k word
we also get emails from all around the
world josh
[Music]
got an email man
[Applause]
featuring kevin's reactions that's right
chris mcdonald writes i've been accused
of being an artist and i've attached a
couple pieces of fan art for you to
enjoy you know we started doing this
show and i told kevin i wanted to
feature stuff that people would mail in
this is the reason why
um when i was a kid in philly there was
kid shows on there where you could mail
in like your sketches and stuff like
wonder ramen yeah in my town in philly
was a guy named captain noah would uh
show your pictures and you could mail it
in and you'd see it on television he'd
hold your [ __ ] up and i remember that
being so cool
so i wanted to do that when we started
doing babylon low those many years ago
and chris has sent in a couple pieces of
fan art which are just really cool can
we show the first one this is uh some of
kevin's characters from all his movies
it's really cool
i like his style
i love the fact that uh parks is uh
front and center yeah
i miss him and then this next one in the
similar style parks is in there twice
you got the tusk got me blowing a guy's
brains out
from red state we got dr josh rausch
i was looking in the corner i was like
[ __ ] josh so thank you chris for
sending those in i love you he's amazing
he does a lot of [ __ ] pieces there's
a piece
here in this room uh a couple weeks ago
we had a contest uh that the the
janesonbob.com website where we
were uh selling movie watches and i
slipped two golden tickets into like two
of them and stuff
and uh the uh uh winner of one of them
uh was shay and shea that what you won
was you come over my house
we watch clerks three and make some
hummus
of course
um so uh
shay uh one she came up from oregon you
want to talk about
frontline worker she too was a [ __ ]
nurse yeah down from oregon my bad
um she brought levi with her and they
have a gift uh for you where are you
kids are you kids nearby one of you come
on is there a what yeah come over there
and shoot if it's hummus i'm good
speaking of which you're good good
hummus like legit right you're not just
saying it because people are looking no
i swear i will take now you get in the
back room and you're like oh my no i'm
going to take it home if you'll if
you'll let me [ __ ]
if you let me
you could eat my hummus
i'm just killing the time until the kids
get i understand feel free
uh here we go this one's levi right here
in this chair give it up for levi and
she's levine shea hi guys
wow
they are delivering an actual piece of
art from chris mcdonald look at that
creepy crown and kevin and the shea
tried to dump this and run but look at
that oh look at that she made a ralph's
custom pop and it's what outfit is it
oh it's you and the yoga hoses and this
little batman comic book that's readable
thank you so much
broke the box man i appreciate that
thank you so much give it up for levi
have they seen the movie yet yeah yeah
they saw it twice they're members of
that kevin smith club which is kind of
like uh you know [ __ ] um
the ralph report yeah and uh the uh we
had a screening couple months ago like
two three months ago or something
so
um when uh shay came to the house like i
certainly recognized shae from a lot of
events that we do and stuff
and she reminded me she was like i saw
it already that was a ghost [ __ ] and
this is the final version she got to see
which
is better we got to put like more stuff
in it including you you were not in the
version that she saw and then tonight
you were in the version that sounds
better to me already
yeah the movie jumped 100 yeah that was
our first note she was like [ __ ] less
ralph
no she was very very happy
anyway uh this next email comes from
elmer he knows i like a cocktail or two
and he thought i might be interested to
know that the oldest pub in britain
is closing its doors after one thousand
two hundred and twenty nine years
it broke my heart elmer also thought
we'd like the name of these players over
a thousand years can we show the name of
the pub
oh [ __ ] the old fighting [ __ ] i guess
now they call the old flappy [ __ ] yeah
exactly [ __ ] can't get hard no more wow
what happens how do you
how do you throw in the towel after
[ __ ] they just went out of business
it's been hurt for sure apparently and
uh they went out of business and they're
closing the doors after one thousand two
hundred and twenty nine years you
imagine like the person that opened that
place if somebody told them like oh this
place is gonna go on for a thousand
years like yeah right yeah and then one
day it's like no it was [ __ ] true
that guy must be really bummed it's
closing yeah yeah yeah he's like how did
it make it a thousand years and then
[ __ ] close
and like pandemic he's like i lived
through the first pandemics right black
dance didn't close this place
[ __ ] we created the pan-dabbing we
kept drinking
we had holes in our guts and the booze
would just flow out go in and go out we
didn't stop
that was our vaccine
uh mike long from harper woods michigan
says hope you're both doing well huge
fan of the show
um as a husband and dad i was wondering
if either of you saw the disney movie
encanto have you seen encanto yet the
disney i have not but i knew the
reference you made with let's not talk
about i saw it with my kid i just loved
that film you went for it big time i'm
gonna watch it soon i just really i
don't have a kid anymore you don't need
one for this you'll you'll love it
you'll dig it it's not i'm just those
the kid flicks don't rise right to the
top of the key watch it
i will if have you watched reacher
no no
then [ __ ] you to death man
well there's like a well-reasoned
response you have gone soft this [ __ ]
reacher program bro it is so
[ __ ] good this is the best review i
could give it if i could dig up my dead
father
which would be a real trick because he
was cremated but if i could [ __ ]
dig him up sit him in front of the tv
reacher would bring him back to life wow
because it's like it was [ __ ] made
for every dad on the planet that's what
i thought and then [ __ ] it turns out
women like it too because this guy's
amazing to look at alan richton he's
dreaming oh not just dreaming man but
like it's
he just [ __ ]
kills people oh that is sexy like left
and [ __ ] right and he gets away with
it it's [ __ ] it's so [ __ ] good man
watch reacher and i'll watch [ __ ]
enchanted or whatever
um
great movie catchy songs i was wondering
though about the catchy song we don't
talk about bruno we're just talking
about that number one by the way on the
charts we don't talk about bruno
what charts the streamers
streaming charts
the song the music charts the music
music charts yeah that's what you're
saying streaming yeah like spotify and
whatnot like music charts yeah like
[ __ ] american top 40. with casey
kaiser
here it is from that movie kevin smith
refuses to watch and gantto
we'll talk about bruno
they're like oh [ __ ] he wants
spider-man to get nominated but he can't
watch in kanto
uh what would it sound like mike long
from harper woods michigan says if it
was sung by arnold schwarzenegger so
we're about
we're about to find out
a little music there josh
we don't talk about roon
we don't talk about rule now now
it was my wedding day
we were getting ready and there wasn't a
cloud in the sky
bruno walks in with an achievious grin
hey hey who's telling this story you or
am i
that's
bruno says it looks like rain
yeah
in doing so he floods my brain
yeah
married in a hurricane
what a joyous day yeah that's hot we
don't talk about bruno no
there you go
we also get emails from folks who find
names of towns that are [ __ ] up we
never got around to naming this segment
so we call it your town's got a [ __ ]
up name
[Music]
you have a quarter
[Laughter]
what happened josh
hand slipped
what are you doing back there
operating a lot of stuff
busy man there's a lot going on it's
like that [ __ ] drummond octopus in
the aquaman movie he's just got hands
everywhere and [ __ ]
uh robert beatty sent this one in he and
his girlfriend were looking at luxury
beach houses on st john in the virgin
islands oh the united states virgin
islands uh st john i believe is a united
states virgin island anyway he found a
community and he said this seems like a
great place and it makes sense it's in
the virgin islands he said can we go to
the united states virgin islands
what's the name of the town he found ah
chocolate hole
welcome to chocolate hole
that's where [ __ ]
her husband's gonna go man alex
that's how that's how you approach that
subject where you're like welcome to
chocolate hole
i've got a vacation home in chocolate
hole
[Laughter]
don't give him a vacation i'll just let
him visit yeah
just the tip and chocolate hole
it's a time share
[Laughter]
that means other people have to live
there sometimes but
what are you gonna do
people also send in things that are
meant for kids you know stuff made for
boys and girls that they're supposed to
enjoy but it turns out they're
inappropriate toys
not appropriate for boys what the [ __ ]
is that inappropriate toys
hold on before you start what did you
get to eat i saw him deliver food and
look [ __ ] good
what was it
lift up your plate i can't see you oh my
[ __ ] that looks amazing
they probably don't have a vegan version
though one day we gotta get some food
while we're doing the show wouldn't that
be hot i mean you're eating hummus i'd
like to eat something yeah we need
something to take up more time up here
you're right
something to slow us down
stop this breakneck pace
take a nap
it'll be amazing if we had an
intermission we can all go out this show
tonight might have been your mission
thank you i got a menu feel free
i'll be over here doing the show let me
know when you're ready to join us
no i'm just i'm just shocked she's just
perusing
i'm in a jacket now i can't be doing any
of this [ __ ] but i do like to look epic
sent this one in this is for kids it's a
book and much like kevin i think this
book is trying to teach them a lesson
early on that life is hardly
disappointing and frustrating can we see
that page
this is i spy something with my little
eye beginning with r
unless i'm missing something
like railroad so i figure railway maybe
maybe railway but [ __ ] that book yeah
if i was a kid that's what i'd be saying
that is a blatant [ __ ] lie
but you know it's not lying man some of
these [ __ ] desserts look really good
[Laughter]
knowing uh how i feel about shit-centric
children's toys let's stop selling our
kids toys that involve them playing with
[ __ ] can we all agree on that in the
21st century
[Applause]
this is the latest one let's take a
picture of this it's called a poop toss
oh that puts it on front street where
you put on a velcro hat and then people
throw [ __ ] at your head
look at this [ __ ]
[Music]
oh what a time he's having
oh isn't this fun
[Music]
pillsbury [ __ ] you pillsbury
i've never seen someone that into a scat
show he's just like really hit me with
[ __ ] it's so hot
um i'll tell you why i wouldn't play
that game i know you're against it
because it's got fake poop i wouldn't
play because that hat looks so stupid
yeah the moment they're like put this on
and be like you're playing alone i'll
throw the [ __ ] how about that
[ __ ] wearing no bathing cap and [ __ ]
it's a good time right here
if they made a baseball cap version well
then i'd play play it looked like a good
time yeah
tim millman sent this one in lastly from
portland oregon this is a mural on his
kids lunchroom wall trying to show you
the benefits of eating veggies you know
vegetables make you strong familiar with
them as a yeah
it's uh here's the the mural it's a
carrot
oh my god it's carrot catching a
football
can we punch in on the bottom half of mr
carrot there
oh my god it's even cut
i think carrots say it's peeled
[Laughter]
best joke you'll heal tonight ladies and
gentlemen i don't uh i don't think kids
need to see the giant carrot [ __ ] that's
not just a [ __ ] [ __ ] that is a
luscious [ __ ] did you see how big that
was [ __ ] a hammer man speaking of
giant hammers you watching pam and tommy
oh yeah
yeah i'm loving the hell out of that
scene isn't it crazy how they put now
you could do nudity without doing nudity
just put prosthetics on people and it
works and [ __ ] like they're showing his
dick
left and right but it's not his dick but
it looks like a dick
[Music]
i mean seth rogen's excellent but she
what's her name lily james james here
give her every [ __ ] emmy you can
write transcendent it's it's crazy it's
[ __ ] i i've seen
the actress like in real life get
interviewed on talk show and i'm like
there's no [ __ ] way that's her yeah
but they put on a prosthetic forehead
[ __ ] teeth nose breasts noses like
not nose they said they were tried for
the nose but they
couldn't find an angle for the nose but
it's crazy the transformation they do on
her he looks good but she looks amazing
yeah it's ridiculous um yeah it's worth
watching kids yeah and a lot of penises
according to kevin smith yeah you'll see
a [ __ ] dick if you've never seen one
this one talks dude
that's what they should put in that
[ __ ] trailer never mind [ __ ] how
amazing she looks like it's the show
where this happens and the dick's like
what
he does he talks to tommy lee i'm not
making that up or not that's [ __ ]
good talking dick it's about the direct
director who did uh i tonya which is
another you know bio picture nice pop
culture satire yeah
uh speaking of pop culture folks left us
recently we like to pay tribute to them
in a segment we call the tinsel towns
and now another edition of
they will be missed ivan reitman
producer director legend passed away at
the age of 75 father of your [ __ ]
childhood yes
and speaking of fatherhood his daughter
catherine years ago yes
travel and she would uh guest co-host
when you weren't available
right you were very tight with catholics
jason very well yeah they're great kids
and he was a great dad from everything
they said did you uh reach out to her
when he passed i did indeed i texted
jason as well and i was like look man
like my heart goes out to you i know how
much you loved him like
i
i lost my dad nearly 20 years ago
and it never stops hurting and that
[ __ ] did not make ghostbusters
so i know
you know you're gonna carry this way for
a long time he's a lovely [ __ ] dude
and he uh he he did love his dad the
only
i wouldn't even call the silver lining
but the only like
good thing is that he got to make
ghostbusters afterlife and his dad got
to [ __ ] see it like that movie was a
love letter and then i did his dad's
work and you know father and son to be
working together and for the father to
see the son making that movie and
[ __ ] you know jason
when he started his career he didn't
want to go anywhere near ghostbusters he
wanted to prove himself and [ __ ] and
then he grew up and got to a place where
he was like it's [ __ ] my family
legacy like why would i run from it and
i'm glad that happened while his dad was
above ground that's so
[ __ ] meaningful and his dad got to
sit there on set like they shot up in
canada like where they're from and stuff
like that so he was not even from canada
where is it czech republic born in
czechoslovakia yeah then moved to canada
and uh produced animal house and of
course
as a director meatballs stripes
ghostbusters
meatball stripes and ghostbusters bang
bang bang three of the greatest [ __ ]
comedies ever made and he made them
successively yeah and then uh
kindergarten cop we'll let him let him
off the hook for them oh what the [ __ ]
it's another
that's awesome
and twins and junior he did three with
schwarzenegger wow
yes look at you you're so small and
don't look like me but with twins
premise of that film was that the
[ __ ] part of that whole movie
um it was i'm pregnant i'm not a woman
but i'm pregnant i'm going to have a
baby that's that movie
you can sum them all up in one sense
wasn't emma tom thompson
was the wife yes yes
it's crazy that arnold did a man
pregnant movie it is
amazing jonathan has passed away at the
age of sixty three yeah you know his
word man have you ever watched him uh i
used to watch him on uh late night yeah
letterman [ __ ] he was funny uh bizarre
gonzo crazy comedian absolutely it's
unfair to compare
apples and oranges but like of the
school of penn teller yeah very
irreverent toward the art darker more uh
more out there i think darker than
[ __ ] penitentiary with the physical
stuff that he would do with his eyeball
would pop out these [ __ ] shoot each
other in the face bro yeah like this guy
cut his tongue open in front of an
audience on a regular basis it was
pretty and then pulled out the rubber
top yeah i know but these [ __ ] shoot
each other in the face for real for real
yeah with [ __ ] glass you could check
the bullet hole they could catch us well
they're shooting glass and they're not
shooting each other in the face oh my
god i'm just saying you're a harsh
critic i just think if you shoot
somebody in the face it would leave a
mark
until [ __ ] penn jillette you got
notes when you do that
um
for me we missed the uh amazing jonathan
man what what a [ __ ] wonderful talent
um subversive as [ __ ] yeah something i
didn't know until he passed away he had
a huge [ __ ] career in vegas
oh yeah yeah massive like i always
thought him as like oh he's the top no
he's in one liner for years yeah making
about three mil a year at bally's on top
of his game what are we doing wrong why
are we making three million a year we
don't do magic and you make hummus
that's all we got
but hummus can be magic if i make it on
stage
in a big showroom in vegas and you do
impressions while i'm doing it you know
i do let's work on that
and lastly sally kellerman classic
actors from the 60s and 70s
uh got her start on the television
during the 60s maybe star trek fans may
remember her from the pilot episode of
star trek where no man has gone before i
think we got a little clip from that
that was the actual fight
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
that'd only be one of you on the end
[Music]
one jealous god
if all this makes a god or is it making
you something else
kirk
absolute power corrupting absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
do it
[Music]
it's hard to tell she's in that show
when shatner's acting yeah
that was the pilot yeah
and they were like let's keep going yeah
but of course uh she's probably best
known for her role as hot lips houlihan
in the classic 1970 robert altman film
mash not for a lot of people though and
not to take anything away from her but
like a lot of people think of loretta
swift because the tv show went on for a
long long time that's true i always
think of her amongst many things she was
an amazing natasha and boris and natasha
very unsung with dave with david thomas
and uh back to school man
she was great she was great and
everything very talented how old
she was 84 years old yes it's a long
life but she deserved more man i agree
um speaking of that big bucket of
winners indeed and who is the other one
oh ivan massive cauldron of [ __ ] yeah
one of the greats
speaking of acting we like to take a
look at acting performances that aren't
always great because we find here on the
show that really bad acting can go all
the way around to become exquisite
acting
welcome to the world of exquisite acting
with ralph garman and kevin smith
[Music]
uh dan ruiz are you here dan where are
you there he is dan's here from
riverside california all the way from
riverside oh [ __ ] and he sent me
relatives from riverside man one of the
first times i came out to california
as a teenager yes
as a teenager was uh
with my mom
i i've been here
when i was nine but
i come back out i was uh
i was 16 years old and
my relatives my mother's relatives lived
in riverside and so i stayed in
riverside and that was the first place
i ever went that had central air
oh my god i sound so boring no it's well
worth it
[Applause]
did they have ice
[Laughter]
i just never i'll never forget that we
had window box units like growing up in
my house this is the first place we went
to
where i was like can you make it cold
where's the air conditioner i'm gonna
sit in front of it and they're like oh
no there is no air conditioner it's
central there i was like where's the air
come from they pointed to the [ __ ]
floor i came up through the [ __ ]
floor so like a dog i would sit right
next to the
[ __ ] vent to try to cool off because
they live this place is [ __ ] hot
right it's [ __ ] hot they would keep
the [ __ ] air conditioning at [ __ ]
78 and it's like what are you nuts drop
that [ __ ] man i'm [ __ ]
anyway riverside rocks
back to you hummus
they were thrilled to have you as a
guest
only is it hot but you're sitting on top
of the grate sucking up all the time
at one point the guy like it was um
uh my mom's uh cousin joanie and uh her
sister dolores why did i talk why that's
on me that's on me i apologize that
one's on me
i don't know what i was thinking i just
and her husband do not engage you should
be the moral
of the story do not engage that's what
ken literally said kevin can you get off
the bench you're gonna break it
and i did i don't think he meant like i
was physically gonna break it oh boy
anyway yeah
that's definitely gonna miss wapner yeah
yeah definitely definitely gonna miss
wahpner yeah
not my underwear
i'm gonna drink now so you got a chance
dan ruiz who we mentioned earlier
sent in this week's submission for
exquisite acting so thank you so much
dan i appreciate that uh this features
lou diamond phillips who can act his
[ __ ] ass off just trust me on this he
just had a big birthday recently god
damn it
this is from young guns
where he played with the native american
running there with billy the kid and
he's talking about how the army wiped
out his people on the reservation
he he's upset
my mother was cut by a saber from her
privates to her neck
my sisters were just babies and they had
their heads bashed in with booty hills
so that the army could save bullets
everybody on my reservation was
butchered and it means nothing to me
[Laughter]
i forgot about that moment in the show
yes yeah that's pretty intense
that's when he was like watching me act
the most
he's good though i buy that that's
that's believable yeah if i was the
director i'd be like right is that your
choice i back it
i'd be like man you ever been to
riverside
it's hot there
first place i ever introduced myself to
central
and in some movies and tv shows they
just leave the mistakes in there
much like this program
we just leave [ __ ] anything in and uh
they don't care about the audience
someone should someone should stand up
and stop
them and say this is [ __ ] that should
not be
[Music]
here's some [ __ ] that should not be
this week's submission for [ __ ] that
should not
no i'm good
this [ __ ] that should not be comes from
dan ruiz from riverside california thank
you so much
man one more you got a hat trick dan is
going to be credited as co-writer on the
show this week
this comes from night uh 2019's clint
eastwood film richard jewell did you see
that about the guy who yeah i did with
uh what's his name um what's the actor's
name what paul walter hauser is that his
name yes i love him and sam um um
rockwell is his lawyer too yeah sam
rockwell as well this is at the end of
the film where the fbi age richard's
been cleared from the the accusations of
the bomb there at the olympic village
and the fbi agents are returning his
belongings that they've taken to
investigate him throughout this
investigation to his uh his place and
his mom there who's it kathy bates is a
mom yeah she's in the kitchen she comes
out to answer the door and the fbi comes
streaming in and then you'll watch them
leave or do they
[Music]
she leaves the kitchen to answer the
front door
here they come fi agents returning all
of his behind
putting him
down and then promptly
walking into the kitchen
and they keep walking to the kitchen
walking into the kitchen
walking into the kitchen no one leaves
they just walk into the kitchen
there's a room jam-packed full of fbi
agents in that house just all crowded in
the kitchen they're all like clint you
sure this is right you'll walk where i
tell you to walk
now walk into the [ __ ] kitchen
i'll tell you when to stop walking
but he was talking to an empty trainer
that's right
we're over here mr eastwood
i like that movie very much i do too
except it's still [ __ ] what is he
like 180 still still could direct the
[ __ ] out of the movie man he's very
talented he wastes very little energy
that's why well i mean that that's why
that like i don't bump into that because
that feels like somebody might be like
clint we should probably have him exit
or something like that and he's just
like too much
i like them going into the kitchen
maybe they get a cold beverage
maybe some hummus
could you imagine yeah oh my god
he makes classics i make hummus what the
[ __ ]
we also talk about the entertainment
news every week we call those the hbo
headlines
[Music]
give me headlines
talking about the uh horrible situation
in the ukraine sean penn is putting
himself in harm's way to do a
documentary about it truly man wherever
there's [ __ ] unrest and trouble
you'll find spicoli these days
which is pretty uh amazing i believe was
he already there shooting something and
then also more broke out and he was just
like uh oh new dog
they said the the war seemed to be
eminent so he went there early to to
shoot footage about the actual invasion
itself this guy who took down [ __ ] el
chapo [ __ ] uh
remember he was in his boat he was
rescuing people in boats yeah he likes
to get involved yeah he does he could
use a hobby
now that is a zombie yes it is see how
can we we don't think like that i'm so
selfish i'm like uh well i'm i'm good so
this guy's out there thinking about
other people and he's an actor and we
all know how [ __ ] selfish actors are
yeah right hey wait a minute
uh speaking of show business and
selfishness the producers of the oscars
are pretty selfish they've cut eight
different categories from the broadcast
this year
yeah really the one that seems people
are most upset about and you'll
appreciate this kevin smith film editing
not getting a live presentation look
i've i would love to [ __ ] give you my
hot take on this but anytime i [ __ ]
say anything on a podcast i get yelled
at on twitter by film twitter
film twitter's like i wish you died
during the heart attack
oh i don't like film twitter
yeah me neither
that being said [ __ ]
how do you make a movie without editing
how do you make a movie the score yeah
how do you make a movie what else sound
design production design makeup and hair
it's crazy that these are categories
that are cut score used to be such a big
[ __ ] deal
that they built dance [ __ ] numbers
around it yeah like you know and they
were interminable but still [ __ ] they
celebrated the score now they're just
like oh we're doing it off camera man
like uh it's in a separate ceremony
um but i you know [ __ ]
in a world where spider-man wasn't one
of the 10 films nominated
i just want to state my case real quick
when they extended it from five
nominations back during the dark night
they were like you know what we're gonna
make a 10 instead of [ __ ] five used
to be five best picture nominations yeah
which was plenty by the way
no kid yeah but they went to 10 because
everyone bitched like dark knight's an
amazing movie you guys had [ __ ]
nominated and [ __ ] and the academy got
scared as they always do and they were
like you know what [ __ ] from now on
we're going to nominate 10 movies and
that'll give you know movies like
everybody had a chance well the idea was
like movies like that could get in the
list yeah you know one of ten as opposed
to one of five and [ __ ]
and so when you know you got one of the
greatest motion pictures
fantasies ever made uh this spider-man
[ __ ] uh no way home picture and [ __ ]
um you know [ __ ] not only does it do
great box office which shouldn't be any
sort of barometer for some merit award
merit but i mean let's be honest like
the award is given from the hollywood
film community to itself so it's not
like you know it's it's necessarily like
you know
getting
some sort of gold star from the
government or something like that which
even right now i don't know if that
means anything
anyway my point being no it's an
industry award and just give it to
themselves yeah and so which is fine why
not [ __ ] yeah but why not celebrate
the industry like you're leaving out
crucial parts
of the industry you're saying that like
you know supposed to be about the making
of movies it's just the famous [ __ ]
people the people that are recognizable
that we want to put on the show and the
people we don't think anyone's going to
recognize will shunt off well the
producers say they feel they have an
obligation to make a good tv show first
and i think that's wrong
i mean [ __ ] yeah we're in the movie
because it never really ends up being a
very good tv show anyways and also like
[ __ ] what they're trying to keep it
under three hours just go for broke man
make it five six who gives a [ __ ] like
you know this is the age of like people
will [ __ ] pause it go take a [ __ ]
jump back in and stuff like make it as
long as you want what are you trying to
keep it tight for you trying to win your
night on the network like
i talked to i don't know if i'm supposed
to say this
oh oh oh
i mean i guess it's nothing that anyone
wouldn't know from just looking at
ratings and stuff but i was talking to
adam goldberg adam goldberg does the
goldbergs ann goldberg said and he
wasn't boasting like it's gonna sound
like he's boasting at first but wait for
the end of it um we were talking about
something about tv and [ __ ] and you know
goldbergs is going on it's like if they
get to go again
it'd be the tenth season
and so
i was like um [ __ ] 10 seasons man
like god when was the last time any show
did that
and he was like i'll do one better
no show will ever do that again
and i was like why and he's like look at
the tv model he's like there's no
netflix does three seasons at best and
out there's no reason for longevity
longevity was about syndication
syndication is [ __ ] dead as they used
to know it and [ __ ] so he's like
i have the number one show on abc
and he's like and we do a 0.5
which for those who are like what does
that mean like that's a pretty
low rating it's under a million people
or something like that supposedly
watching based on nielsen which is math
i never quite understood
but you know there's numbers like basic
cable used to get back in the day bro
[ __ ] comic book men pulled double
that you know on midnight but that was
after the walking dead we were just
riding robert kirkman's giant [ __ ]
but still like it's just it's eroding
because people have choice now they're
like oh i'll [ __ ] i'll flip over to
hbo max i'll go to apple tv i'll go to
[ __ ] netflix i'll go to hulu so many
different [ __ ] choices at this point
why would you ever like tv is one of
your last choices because tv is still
the place where you know they're like oh
phooey
you know like [ __ ] if you want to
watch someone be like [ __ ] like go watch
a [ __ ] stream or a movie there's no
talking dicks on nbc damn skippy right
this is us would be interesting if one
of their dicks talked oh
could you imagine milo ventimiglia's
dick just comes out and does a
[Music]
do you watch that show no i just think
he burns
i knew about it that much as well
and before we go home tonight please uh
think a good thoughtful for sylvester
stallone i feel bad for him uh he just
sold his
mansion here in southern california he's
moving to palm beach florida
what yes that's where the elderly go
right
oh yeah well you know
i'm like a hundred
you can't tell because i'm in really
good shape for a hundred but every
single time you you look great i do look
great don't get me wrong but i'm inside
i'm rotting away
how old is he do you know uh
73
i want to say that's so [ __ ] up my mom
just turned 76. how much could she bench
press nothing
not at all
anyway he just sold he had to take a big
loss on the house that's why i feel bad
how much he was asking for 110 million
holy [ __ ] and he only got uh 58 million
dollars for his house
so please on your way home dude
i know you'll be thinking about your own
problems but how about this just though
just sparing a moment for stallone
taking a bath on his house for half of
what most of us uh you know have ukraine
in our thoughts and prayers but hey how
about sly yeah what the [ __ ] yeah
what did he buy it for anybody know uh
because that would make the difference
it does not say so he made money he put
on the market for 110 that didn't bite
then 80 and he had to finally sell it at
58. but the new place he got in florida
he got for 35 so he's still making about
20 million dollars on the deal so the
rich get richer and do the indeed they
do
and it says here this mansion
central air conditioning kev oh [ __ ] so
you know it's fancy you know it's one of
them fancy joints riverside style that's
right
we can't help it we got to talk about
justin
bieber justin bieber
nobody [ __ ] needs you
you wanna know why
i'll tell you why
cause you're a little [ __ ] that's right
justin bieber
did save tim tim torton's they were the
tim hortons people were to be crazy
appreciative to him like thank you
superman you saved tim hortons but on
the upside he's also tested positive for
covin so
we got that going he's got it yes and so
he had to cancel uh several shows
including one in tacoma tonight tacoma
washington show tonight was cancelled
because of his covet so see it's not all
bad news about covet 19. think of those
good people in tacoma who have been
spared
i mean i can imagine he's got to be
vexed and boosted right i guess but
somehow he got it and so they're worried
about the team i guess and so they're
going to hold off and reschedule all
those dates
[Music]
again
always happens to the best people right
i know
they say he's fine so it's not all good
news but he's not
he's not in that life-threatening age
ranges no not from kovid
can i say a quick [ __ ] story before
we jump into geek news i wish i could
stop you somehow
[Laughter]
but i know better
it happened on the way here so i was
[ __ ] driving here and uh
i
like saw a police car very close to mine
yeah and i you know [ __ ] i i don't
wear my seatbelt i don't know why
because i was raised in a generation
where they didn't make you do that
instead
you can't learn stuff after you've been
raised in a generation we all know that
no you can't make a decision later in
life and say
maybe i'll save my life with this piece
of vinyl i'll strap across my chest old
dog new tricks that kind of thing so
i was uh i'm pulling up like kind of
near
the police and i'm trying to hold back
but then there's somebody coming behind
me and there's an awkward space between
me and the car in front of me so i pull
up and i don't look over but i get the
distinct impression
that they're looking at me and i'm like
[ __ ] they tell that i'm not buckled
in because my seat belt is buckled
behind me yeah so it looks like so you
do buckle it let me get this straight
it's not the it's a pain ass to actually
buckle the belt you'll take the time to
buckle the belt
without yourself sitting in the chair
yes and then you'll lean back on the
seat belt after it's been buckled well i
buckled it once and then never again so
that's the idea
so but you can see if you're right next
to me and stuff and they were in one of
those higher you know suv cars and stuff
so i was like oh [ __ ] and i felt them
looking at me and so everyone's driving
like the speed limit [ __ ] even though
normally we wouldn't and we're heading
for that bridge to burbank and he the
police car shuffles in behind me and
stuff and then i make that i
put on my blinker because i got to get
into the turning lane come on over here
police car seems to be following me and
i'm like you know what here we go this
dude's probably like he's just going
into burbank and stuff like that
stopped at the light
got into the other lane to be closer to
the building where i'm gonna make the
turn to come here and [ __ ]
cars right behind me and stuff and i'm
like [ __ ] and so i get up to the right
in front of the place here like people
were still lined up and whatnot and the
police car pulls up [ __ ] right next
to me and [ __ ] and finally i just have
to look because it feels like something
is going on i look over and the two cops
are looking at me and they go
[Laughter]
which i hope was for silent bob oh okay
if not what do they think i saw
[Laughter]
and do i want to leave tonight
because maybe i missed the next move
which was
[Laughter]
anyway oh that's a good one thank you
yeah back to geek news hey let's hear
some geek news what do you say rock and
cabin raffling kevin ruffin cams
[Music]
speaking of spider-man as you were
earlier uh tom holland revealed a secret
this week that no one else knew what one
of the three spider-man he says i'll
give you a spoiler i'm not going to tell
you who but one of us has a fake ass in
their suit
you can figure that out for yourselves
one of the spider-men we were watching
in that film had a false ass
fake ass
so obviously we eliminate him
i assume if he probably wouldn't write
himself out if he had to put a fake ass
in his pants or maybe not i don't know
did anybody see what's the new movies in
uncharted
uncharted it's andrew yeah you say that
like you know
[Laughter]
how do you know andrew has needs a fake
ass
you've seen his real ass
machine is realized in movies or in real
life
[Laughter]
you've seen it in real life but not
naked
like under a sheet or something
[Laughter]
do tell
anyway it's not as juicy as what you're
saying so he wore inserts to give him
more [ __ ] junk in the truck bit of a
flat butt
let's go
uh marvel confirmed the rumor and said
paul bettany also did it for the vision
i mean do you think they asked him first
he was like [ __ ] you marvel
you're exposing my ass yeah yeah i never
looked at his ass but [ __ ] did he look
amazing in that [ __ ] crew the
turtleneck sweater he wore in the last
episode and [ __ ]
like right well before he disappeared
yeah i mean spoilers but uh
he looks [ __ ] good man spoilers
usually comes before the thing
uh but everyone's talking of course
about batman which comes out in about a
week did you see google what google did
for batman
search engine google no
what did they do for that show a little
video what happens when you search
something with batman on google
type in something like bruce wayne or
whatever right and then when the search
engine comes up you'll find a little
um bat signal
like
icon there and if you click on that
the bat signal lights up and batman
flies across the screen
[Music]
sweet it's pretty cool it must have cost
a fortune they did it themselves google
for the [ __ ] of it yes could you imagine
your warner brothers then they tore
warner and they said yeah okay we're
good with that they're like we're ready
to spend [ __ ] 100 million to mark at
the movie google's like here's 200
million for free do something free
[ __ ] the rich get richer um we're
going to see batman
march 1st thanks claire claire are you
here yeah claire everyone give it up for
claire
thank you claire
um we're going to go see it march 1st
there's an event at or the first
screening or something at the chinese
theater and
claire is so [ __ ] tight with
everybody but particularly the chinese
theater people and stuff she was the
pathway to which jay and i got our hand
prints and footprint in the cement in
the chinese theater courtyard so thank
you um
but uh
she's so tight with them like uh when uh
what was it uh
carnage
came out [ __ ] venom let there be
carnage right she was like do you want
to go say to the chinese we can go up to
the private suites
and upstairs they have these two
private [ __ ] suites where like i
guess the [ __ ] cocaine hookers are
kept i guess they got all these pictures
upstairs of like old hollywood and [ __ ]
he's been there for [ __ ] years and
stuff but it's so [ __ ]
dope it's an incredible view you're
almost like you can you can't quite
reach it because it's the middle of the
room but you're very you're as high as
the chandelier and you know the
chandelier is very ornate yeah
we went and me red and uh and claire
watched carnage like we were the only
[ __ ] people there and stuff i don't
think it's going to be that way for the
batman i think it's going to be a pact
maybe a few people there yeah yeah but
that's gonna be [ __ ] dope looking
forward to it pays to no [ __ ] people
man looking forward to michael keaton's
return as batman as well yeah did you
see his uh instagram this week that is
just a selfie of his shadow i can't
[ __ ] wait man like i i think this is
a wonderful idea i like too i i enjoy dc
stepping into the multiverse and i can't
i never thought we'd get another
michael keaton [ __ ] batman like
think about it we only got to see him do
it twice yeah now we're going to just
and twice over the course of like four
years we're gonna see him do it twice in
the span of one year first in flash and
then he's in batgirl as well yep so [ __ ]
man all the keaton
all right it's almost time for us to say
goodbye actually it's way that past that
time but we're still here but we are
we are going to oh my god yeah
it sure is
it's still enough time to talk about the
size of the penis of one of our favorite
actors liam neeson
[Applause]
[Music]
if you've got a fact you'd like to share
about the size of liam's [ __ ] you can
write what is that language where is she
from maybe she was from swedish i
believe it was swedish it was swiss
sweats
swiss german
you people know more at the show we do
that's obvious
yeah yeah
um if you have a fact you'd like to
share with us or anything you'd like to
send your uh our way hbo podcast aol.com
here's the first fact liam neeson's [ __ ]
is so big
it bought sylvester stallone's mansion
for 58 million dollars
i didn't know it was doing that well but
it got a good price too
william niece's [ __ ] is so big
kanye west is scared to beef with it on
social media
that's the only only thing i think he's
scared of leonie's [ __ ] is so big
it has a starring role in the upcoming
jurassic world dominion
i think we have a picture from the set
don't we josh
it's got some prosthetics on him but you
can you can recognize him you can see
that it's him
[ __ ] cockasaurus you can tell
because you could still see him in there
somewhere
liam neese's [ __ ] is so big
brandon tweets let's go liam
flip that around you had to go political
there i didn't it's just the thing
people say
and lastly liam neeson's [ __ ] is so big
it [ __ ] tom holland and both tobey
maguire and andrew garfield also felt it
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen of burbank have you
had a good time this evening
thank you so much for coming out and
joining us we appreciate it i can't
thank you enough for being here but
let's be honest there is no show without
the man sitting next to me give it up
for mr ralph [ __ ] garmin
let's hear it for my bestest babble
buddy mr kevin smith
and that my friends is hollywood babylon
for this week i'm kevin smith i'm ralph
carpenter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a
ten year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
jay and sam bob get old i'm kevin smith